Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Agents of SHIELD Episode
3 video.
I feel like this season has done a good job
of one-upping itself every single episode.
And even though fight club here was really
badass, I still feel like Fitz and Simmons
was the best storyline.
It's so weird and awesome to see like what
a 180 those two characters are done since
last season like Hunter was always a fun character
like it was it was such a win when they brought
him on the show to ruin the surprise of the
season three has been fit send Simmons just
careful for spoilers as we get into it something
to do top five WTF moments and I'll try to
explain where some of this is going some of
the twists were very obviously telegraphed
like we knew all about the Hunter Hydra stuff
that was gonna happen that I wasn't surprised
at all the Simmons stuff was the surprise
starting with number five though Coulson and
Rosalind are going to be working together
in their count like twins Stephen has her
own male gendered version of Lola eyes up
here buddy every missing hand joke that you
could possibly imagine you didn't divide that
their kind like this old married couple like
they have this instant rapport with each other
they just this witty banter words like they
don't hate each other but they pretend that
they do if they ever got to buddy buddy I
feel like it would ruin things like just the
way things are right now just just perfect
just more of this than working together like
that phone call to the end is just the sign
that you're going to get a lot more scenes
with them like you're going to see more moments
like this happen more frequently yes Daisy
is just about it but this is actually not
a bad thing if if Roslyn were going to be
evil they would present her is evil they just
want you to think that she's going to be an
antagonist obviously shingles are going to
fight it out for most of the season then the
work together because a bigger threat will
come along as of right now the big candidates
for that are ward with hydraulic he's slowly
rebuilding Hydra then there's Lash and then
there's whatever is going on on Simmons planet
those three things all much bigger threat
than Roslyn's organization on the number for
the Lincoln on the run so very clearly they
were going to bring him and eventually I'm
I'm kinda glad they didn't draw this out too
long because you think by now he would already
come to his senses and try to work with team
Coulson or been captured by Rosalind's group
didn't amazing job of presenting his relationship
with this sober companion it sounds like he
was actually an alcoholic in the past with
suicidal tendencies the very clearly there's
trauma and Lincoln's past we haven't seen
yet the trauma was like a big theme in this
episode Pete PTSD people trying to survive
trauma Simmons is just like the very obvious
face that you have like Coulson who is trying
to get over is missing hand you have Daisy
this trying to get over losing her mother
lots of people with PTSD all over the show
so when Lincoln accidentally killed his friend
you actually actually felt that they did a
really good job of establishing the rapport
this is in the first time he called me so
like definitely high five so the writers for
that anytime you can make a really brief appearance
by character really compelling it is always
a giant when but on the number three drinks
of the British pub so main Hunter very clearly
trying to infiltrate what they find out is
Hydra and I don't know that they know that
it's Hydra but I think they have an idea the
whole all ideas that may in Hunter are going
after wards they need to infiltrate Hydra
to do that this guy here is there in the need
to fight their way and if you ever watched
the first ninja turtles movie were the Yugo
like down the levels of the foot clans training
center like you have to win your way into
the foot so the minute they establish that
Hunter was going to have to fight his way
and all I could think about was that old ninja
turtles movie if it'd actually been ninja
turtles though they may would like to lick
the lights out and beat everyone up that afflict
them back on to make a look like Hunter did
it but he goes full on rage face pulls out
the brass knuckles in the funny thing is is
that even though his name is Hunter on the
TV show the actor's name is Nick blood and
he winds up covered in blood on the show so
thus far this is my new favorite reaction
Faison agent to shield season three when he
gets taken I feel like most people kinda knew
that this person was wards second-in-command
so it's like okay so when they panned over
and you see the Hydra feel like if you still
feel like it's still a big moment but you
kinda saw it coming in the distance on the
number two this tries to help Simmons re-acclimate
to life on earth the whole Simmons set up
was great just like the way that she is reacting
to all these Earth-based sounds it sounds
like what happened is she just learned associate
certain sounds with the people they were hunting
her or the things they said there was flora
but not gonna that means there were plants
on the alien world that she didn't see any
animals so assume when they said there weren't
any animals they were they were talking about
whatever was hunting her but essentially she
just exhibiting classic PTSD like you know
you come back from a war and you just you
can't handle all the sites and sensations
from everything just because you're so used
to the alien environment of where you've been
but actually if you seen the Martian this
past weekend the Ridley Scott movie they get
really science see about what it's like to
live in a foreign environment the actually
kinda did that in this episode several he
appreciated it but there are actually some
really serious consequences to your body being
in an alien environment for an extended period
spoiler alert if you going to space you will
be supercool but it will destroy your body
so of anything Simmons should be more strung
out but I mean this is TV so they don't want
you want to linger too much in the moment
she still gonna be experiencing like these
these crazy side effects but now she has a
purpose which can adopt a lesson in my number
one WTF moment Simmons is trying to get back
to the alien planet the shocking twist isn't
so much that she's trying to get back it's
that everything that we've seen from her character
makes it seem like that was a terrible place
that you would never want to go back to she
already told Fitz that her curiosity died
when the fear said in so what is it that she's
trying to get back to very clearly it something
Kree related because the deKree monolith that
took her there but I'm just guessing that
it's more complicated than some sort of like
weird human hunting future sport planet is
probably another Kree outpost with other in
humans living there we haven't seen a whole
lot evidence yet but I am expecting that to
loopback around on the last plot like Bill
tie Lash to this other place this is the planet
in the comments though Lash showed up on earth
so that they might just keep him there but
I be totally cool they change things in the
comics make time to this alien planet because
clearly he has to have a reason for wanting
to kill all these other new in humans we don't
know that they're doing the exact comic book
storyline in the comics he just he went around
killing new in humans because he thought they
were unworthy of taking in the Terrigen Mists
let me know in the comments what do you think
it is that Simmons is trying to get back to
that planet for what is it that so important
on that terrible -looking planet that she
has to get back to really this episode was
Easter egg like there weren't too many references
to comic book storylines I mean we really
we haven't really seen Lash in a while either
he's the closest thing to a comic book storyline
we have secret warriors is a comic book storyline
to Coulson just explained it was going to
try and put a team together but that didn't
happen eventually it will definitely happen
and we will see a secret warriors team doing
of the really funny thing about this episode
is isn't comic book related it was just when
they were doing that video game integration
like anytime characters play a videogame in
the lingers on the sKreen is probably because
the videogame people paid for them to put
it in the TV show I totally cool with it they
did a Jaguar add the other week whenever world
was driving the Jaguar round but because I'm
moving into a new apartment next week suddenly
in this scene that couch became the most interesting
character I just think it's funny how sometimes
like objects or locations can be characters
in and of themselves as a really big news
is tonight working to meet anarchy on arrow
season four so be sure to check the episode
out post my video after it airs I'm doing
the reverse flash ring giveaway so be sure
to subscribe to get everything is any other
Marvel videos you guys want me to do this
week just let me know of I've already done
a daredevil trailer video punisher, Elektra,
can be freaking awesome I am talking to Netflix
about doing some special Jessica Jones related
stuff but that might not happen for a couple
weeks to get all lucky because posted of something
really cool up happening so I guess with arrow
the post tonight you can click here for my
daredevil season two trailer and you can click
here for my flash episode two video from last
night thank you so much watching everybody
high five and I'll see you guys in a little
bit!